[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und bettina schausten
guten abend herr putin schaden will
spart energie robert habeck griffiger
aufruf ist vor allem ein appell an sich
selbst denn der
bundeswirtschaftsminister muss in diesen
wochen abbauen was deutsche politik in
jahrzehnten zuvor aufgebaut hat die
abhängigkeit von russischem öl und gas
was das öl angeht hat habe ich diese
woche vollzug gemeldet der verbrauch aus
russischen importen sei in den letzten
wochen so gesenkt worden dass für
deutschland jetzt ein öl-embargo
schmerzhaft aber handhabbar sei ein
problem allerdings bleibt und es liegt
im brandenburgischen schwedt nicola
albrecht berichtet sie speist sich aus
den erdölfeldern im westen sibiriens und
endet unter anderem genau hier in der
raffinerie schwedt in der
brandenburgischen uckermark die pipeline
namens durch bar auf deutsch
freundschaft doch mit dem russischen
angriffskrieg ist es mit der
freundschaft vorbei und die raffinerie
wird über nacht vom zentralen versorger
der region zur herzkammer des problems
sich vom russischen öl unabhängig zu
machen und eine einfache lösung gibt es
nicht die lösung würde so aussehen dass
wir über den hafen rostock zur
raffinerie schwedt bekommen allerdings
gibt es eine kritische grenze die nicht
unterschritten werden darf weil dann
kann die raffinerien nicht mehr
betrieben werden doch nicht russisches
öl für schwedt und wie es in
ausreichender menge und qualität dort
hinkommt ist nicht das einzige problem
die raffinerie die 95 prozent der
versorgung mit benzin diesel heizöl und
kerosin in berlin und brandenburg
gewährleistet und auch polen anteilig
versorgt ist de facto in russischer hat
die raffinerie schwedt die wirklich
betrieben von rosneft rost nicht bis ein
russischer staatskonzern und die hand
natürlich gar keine interessen daran
dass sie nicht russisches öl raffinieren
also wenn ich da anruft und sagt hallo
was wollt ihr eigentlich tun um
unabhängig zu werden
die hörer gar nicht ab und sagen hey was
willst du eigentlich von uns das ist
genau unser geschäftsmodell nichts
werden wir dagegen tun
rosneft hält 54 prozent der anteile der
raffinerien in schwedt und will
eigentlich sogar noch mehr im
vergangenen jahr gibt es sein
vorkaufsrecht auf die anteile des shell
konzerns aus ziel mehr als 90 prozent
das bundeskartellamt stimmt dem deal
drei tage vor dem einmarsch russischer
truppen in der ukraine zu bedenken aus
der politik gibt es zu diesem zeitpunkt
ebenfalls keine vor allem nicht in
brandenburg ich selber bin definitiv ein
anhänger in der politik die über jahre
betrieben worden ist wandel durch handel
ich glaube das war ein richtiges konzept
wenn wir diesen weg der ost politik
nicht beschritten werden würde ich nicht
in einem wiedervereinigten berlin und
deutschland leben das heute die eine
oder andere entscheidung rückwirkend
eine andere bewertung bekommt dass es
nachvollziehbar aber wie gesagt
hinterher ist man immer schlauer heute
ist sich die bundesregierung einig
russland soll nicht mehr große teile der
ostdeutschen infrastruktur kontrollieren
dürfen möglichkeiten der
treuhandverwaltung oder gar enteignung
werden geprüft das neue energie
sicherungs gesetz soll es ermöglichen
vor ort in der uckermark dagegen lehnen
viele unternehmer ein öl-embargo
vehement ab und auch bewohner und
lokalpolitiker fürchten sich vor den
möglichen konsequenzen
am russischen öl hängen arbeitsplätze
und es gehört auch seit langem zur dna
der region in vielen anderen gegenden
sind die menschen sicherlich nicht so
industrie affin aber entsteht ist es
wirklich so dass es ein beruhigendes
gefühl es für uns wenn die arbeit läuft
wenn die fackel brennt und auf so eine
situation wie sie jetzt das kann man
sich nicht vorbereiten immerhin eine
gute nachricht gebe es heute erklärt uns
der brandenburgische wirtschaftsminister
der shell konzern sei bereit bis auf
weiteres seine anteile zu halten damit
die fackel in schwedt weiter brennt
aber muss sie unbedingt mit öl aus
russland brennen sprechen wir mit einer
frau die sich mit dem thema energie
wirklich bestens auskennen professor
veronika grint volkswirtin an der
universität erlangen-nürnberg ist
mitglied im sachverständigenrat zur
begutachtung der gesamtwirtschaftlichen
entwicklung also eine der
wirtschaftsweisen schönen guten abend
wir erreichen sie in hamburg
guten abend verschossen frau professor
grimm wie kann ihrer meinung nach eine
lösung für schwedt aussehen um um
rosneft klein zu halten ist staatlicher
aufsicht also am ende gar enteignung ist
ja heute diskutiert worden ist im
bundestag kein gangbarer weg
ja es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten es
gibt die möglichkeit tatsächlich zu
enteignen es gibt auch die möglichkeit
in die treuhandverwaltung zu gehen was
davon die bessere alternative ist das
wird sich auch herausstellen das hängt
auch davon ab von wo schmid dann
beliefert wird man hört ja dass polen
nur dann beliefern will wenn tatsächlich
russland die raffinerie nicht mehr
kontrolliert und von solchen dingen wird
es abhängen ist jetzt natürlich schon
viel geschafft worden bei der
unabhängigkeit von russischem öl aber
die abhängigkeit konzentriert sich jetzt
sehr stark auf diese raffinerien im
osten und das muss noch geregelt werden
und weil sie eben auch so wichtig ist
für den nordosten für die hauptstadt den
flughafen ist das russische öl denn
wirklich zu ersetzen sie haben es gerade
schon angesprochen mit dem blick auf
polen ist ist das zu ersetzen dann mit
tankern in rostock oder eben danzig an
kommen müssten und woher kommt dann das
öl eigentlich
ja es gibt verschiedene studien die sich
damit befassen
die kommen zu dem ergebnis dass
russische öl ist zu ersetzen aber es
geht natürlich mit belastungen für die
wirtschaft in deutschland und in europa
einher wenn man darauf verzichten wollen
würde insofern ist es immer die frage ob
man diesen schritt gehen möchte und das
ziel muss natürlich seien die immensen
zahlungen die aktuell aus der
europäischen union an russland geleistet
werden zu reduzieren aktuell zahlen wir
ja 20 milliarden euro ungefähr pro monat
für russische energielieferungen und das
ist natürlich geld das spiel räume
schafft in russland und darauf muss
eigentlich die europäische politik
abzielen diese spielräume zu reduzieren
habeck sagt ja jetzt auch wir sind
bereit wären bereit für ein öl embargo
es würde zwar weh tun ist aber jetzt wie
er sagt und wie es auch immer heisst
handhabbar erfüllt es denn tatsächlich
den zweck den sie auch ansprechen würde
es putin dennoch empfindlich schaden ein
öl embargo
ja es ist so dass große summen
überwiesen werden nach russland 20
millionen euro pro monat und damit
werden importe realisiert damit wird der
rubel gestützt und damit werden auch
söldner bezahlt wie es heißt und das
schafft natürlich spielräume für
russland die eskalation weiterzuführen
es ist nicht klar dass damit unmittelbar
der krieg finanziert wird aber es
schafft natürlich für die wirtschaft
spielräume diesen konflikt weiter zu
eskalieren
und man muss natürlich jetzt alles daran
setzten dann die spielräume reduziert
werden den konflikt zu eskalieren oder
auch auf andere regionen in europa
auszuweiten deutlich abhängiger als vom
öl ist deutschland vom russischen gas
sie haben sich verschiedentlich
professor grimm für ein gas boykott auch
ausgesprochen aus den gründen die sie
uns gerade genannt haben wogegen jetzt
die industrie sturm läuft gerade heute
der basf chef der sagt ein gasstopp
jetzt würde zu einer irreversiblen
schädigung der volkswirtschaft führen
sie bestreiten das
es ist so dass verschiedene studien
nahelegen dass wir einen
wirtschaftseinbruch erleiden würden
ungefähr 3 prozentpunkte bis sechs
prozent weniger als das aktuell
prognostizierte wirtschaftswachstum das
heißt wir würden in einer rezession sein
es ist aber so dass auch die
vorbereitung auf einen lieferstopp der
uns hier einfach auch treffen kann weil
putin und den gashahn abdrehte dir die
ist wichtig wir müssen also gas aus
anderen regionen beschaffen wir müssen
gas einsparen wo immer das geht und das
sind vorbereitungen die müssen wir so da
so treffen da haben wir uns im
sachverständigenrat auch sehr klar
geäußert dass das mit aller vehemenz
vorangetrieben werden sollte und was
natürlich auch noch zu berücksichtigen
ist ist dass die energiekosten wenn wir
von russland unabhängig werden wollen
die werden natürlich steigen auch wenn
wir auf längere sicht von russland
unabhängig werden wollen wird das zu
höheren energiekosten führen und die
besorgnis aus der industrie wird
natürlich auch daher ganz kurz noch zu
höheren kosten wenn nichts mehr da es
wäre hat vorrang bisher sind das die
privathaushalte
da sagt die industrie jetzt da sollte
man doch vielleicht die reihenfolge
umdrehen zuerst die industrie um
arbeitsplätze zu erhalten muss ja was
geändert werden kurze antwort bitte
ja das ist schwierig die privathaushalte
kann man nicht einfach vom gas ab kappen
aber man kann natürlich einsparen um
dann die lücke so gering wie möglich zu
halten frau poster grimm interessante
einsichten ganz herzlichen dank für
heute abend
ich danke ihnen
einen gruß aus moskau wenn die
ukrainische regierung den angriff auf
kiew gestern während des besuchs des
un-generalsekretärs gute risch ein gruß
aus zynismus und verachtung gegenüber
den opfern des krieges nach fast zwei
wochen pause trafen raketen unter
anderem ein wohnhaus eine journalistin
des senders radio liberty kam bei dem
angriff ums leben im osten des landes
wird weiter gekämpft in mario pohl
sollte heute ein versuch unternommen
werden zivilisten aus dem belagerten
stahlwerk heraus zu bringen wo sich auch
noch viele verletzte aufhalten auf den
weg in die umkämpfte region dann jetzt
hat sich unser reporter daran sade
gemacht seine fahrt führte ihn bis nach
bukowski
an die front
wir fahren in die region donetsk
richtung front
im radio halbstündliche warnungen und
sicherheitshinweise wir nähern uns den
shuttle
programms die letzte stadt vor der front
noch sind hier die kriegsschäden
vergleichsweise gering
wir treffen nicolai er ist für die
sicherheit in der stadt verantwortlich
er war polizistin mario pohl und ist es
jetzt hier er hat erlebt was russische
bomben anrichten seine wohnung oben
hatte meerblick sein sofa steht unten
auf trümmern
bei luftangriffen einschlägen von
mörsern oder explosionen schicken wir
die leute in die keller die wir
vorbereitet haben die sind mit wasser
essen und medikamenten ausgestattet da
können wir lange durchhalten
ihre bunker sie sollen selbst einer
wochenlang belagerung einer einkesselung
standhalten selbst brunnen für wasser
haben sie gebohrt und spielzeug für
kleinkinder gesammelt
es bricht mir das herz die kinder meine
enkelin zum glück ist sie nicht mehr
hier bei explosion pinkelte sie sich
immer ein ist dass sein leben für kinder
essensausgabe
die menschen haben keine arbeit mehr
leben nur noch von ihren ersparnissen
ohne hilfe würden sie hungern
eine tüte sie muss für zwei tage reichen
wir kaufen nur brot selbst im moment
gibt es kaum zucker auch kein mehl den
rest tauschen wir untereinander
wir essen kein fleisch das macht fett
wir werden alle dünn werden
humor aus verzweiflung begegnet uns hier
häufig wie der versuch normalität
aufrechtzuerhalten
maria die abgeordnete des bürgermeisters
hat die verwaltung um strukturiert so
dass sie auch bei belagerungen
arbeitsfähig wären
wir beamte können jetzt nicht gehen es
ist unmöglich wie würden wir uns dann
fühlen wie ein verräter nein das ist
nicht unser weg
von ehemals 70.000 menschen in bottrop
sind knapp 20.000 geblieben
der blick vom stadtrand hinter dem feld
am horizont ist der krieg
leben nah an der front von bukowskis
wieder zurück ins depot garagen zu dem
wir müssen noch mal nachfragen es gab
heute nämlich den ganzen tag über
meldungen es könne vielleicht eine
operation zur evakuierung des stahlwerks
in mariupol geben um zivilisten
verletzte kinder zu retten zuletzt war
das ja immer gescheitert was hören sie
aus mario pohl gibt es anzeichen dass
eine rettung heute klappen könnte
im moment gibt es keine neuen
informationen darüber ob eine
evakuierung der eingeschlossenen
zivilisten in mariupol heute nacht oder
gar einen morgenstunden stattfinden soll
denn selensky hatte am abend in seiner
ansprache mario pohl zwar erwähnt aber
kein wort zur evakuierung gesagt die
busse stehen bereit zur abholung doch
auf der ukrainischen seite fehlt es an
vertrauen bei den zivilisten aber auch
bei der regierung zu oft hat die
russische armee flüchtlinge auf ihren
flucht korridoren beschossen die
russische seite und das ist zynisch zu
sagen weiß um die tatsache dass die
zivilisten eine große belastung für die
ukrainische kämpfer im stahlwerk
darstellen laut dem ukrainischen
kommandeur volina ist das so dass noch
hunderte von zivilisten dort sind
darunter gar ein baby
dankeschön für den aktuellen stand dara
hassanzadeh
ja ein einziges deutsches idol ist heute
tief gefallen zum fall boris becker
gleich mehr in dieser sendung zunächst
weitere wichtige nachrichten des tages
mit heinz wolf an der spitze der
europäischen grenzschutzagentur frontex
wird es einen wechsel geben der
verwaltungsrat der behörde gab den
rücktritt des bisherigen chefs fabrice
brégier bekannt als hintergrund gelten
insbesondere ermittlungen zur so
genannten push becks der illegalen
zurückweisung von migranten im fokus der
vorwürfe steht immer wieder auch die
griechische grenzschutz berichten
zufolge sollen führungskräfte von
frontex verstöße absichtlich vertuscht
haben frontex einheiten unterstützen eu
staaten an ihren außengrenzen
die bundeswehr beteiligt sich für ein
weiteres jahr an dem eu-einsatz vor der
libyschen küste der bundestag erteilte
ein weiteres mandat bis ende april 2023
die bundeswehr soll weiterhin aufgaben
wie die seeraumüberwachung und
aufklärung übernehmen und dafür wie
bisher bis zu 300 soldatinnen und
soldaten entsenden können
zur geplanten verkürzung der isolations
zeit bei einer corona infektion auf fünf
tage gibt es unterschiedliche reaktionen
die deutsche stiftung patientenschutz
kritisierte nicht die politik sondern
das virus und die infektion müssten die
schutzmaßnahmen bestimmen der
vorstandsvorsitzende der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
gassen verwies dagegen auf eine hohe
dunkelziffer womit es eine
scheinsicherheit sei zum einen mit
diesen isolations pflichten relevant in
das infektionsgeschehen einzugreifen
die evangelische kirche in deutschland
trauert um ihren ehemaligen
ratsvorsitzenden und früheren berliner
bischof martin kruse die ekd teilte mit
der theologe sei im alter von 93 jahren
gestorben
martin kruse gehörte dem rat der ekd von
1979 bis 1991 an ab 1985 war er sechs
jahre lang vorsitzender er hatte sich
unter anderem für die ökumene eingesetzt
die ekd-vorsitzende kurschus würdigte
gosch als einen brückenbauer mit weitem
horizont
nach einer vergleichsweise ruhigen woche
hat es heute wieder gewaltsame
auseinandersetzungen zwischen
israelischen sicherheitskräften und
palästinensischen jugendlichen am
tempelberg in jerusalem gegeben die
jugendlichen hätten vor der al aksa
moschee feuerwerkskörper gezündet und
steine geworfen so örtliche medien die
sicherheitskräfte setzten gummigeschosse
und blendgranaten ein mehr als 40
palästinenser sollen verletzt worden
sein
jahrzehntelang blieb er der 17-jährige
leimener boris becker deutsches bobbele
der das tennis wunder in wimbledon
schaffte ungestüm unverstellt
liebenswert seine frühen erfolge machten
ihn zur legende zum star zu ikone danach
begann eine zeit in der er so
verschwenderisch wie zunehmend peinlich
agierte zuletzt wurde all dem ruhm immer
ein ex hinzugefügt ex legende und ex
ikone
leichtgläubig und naiv sei er gewesen
aber nie kriminell so versuchte sein
anwalt ihn zu verteidigen das londoner
gericht hält ihn für einen vorsätzlichen
betrüger und wieder als täter nun sitzt
der ex hält im gefängnis eine tragödie
erzählt von andreas stamm sein letzter
gang in freiheit boris becker mit
lebenspartnerin lilian die cavalli
monteiro alles gute schallte es aus der
versammelten presse
ab vertrauen das will er ausstrahlen
doch die gepackte sporttasche die er im
gerichtssaal trägt verrät der 54 jährige
ist sich bewusst er steht vor der
größten niederlage seines lebens gepackt
für diese fahrt am nachmittag vom
londoner gericht geht es direkt ins
gefängnis am selben ort an dem seine
tennis-karriere an fahrt aufnahm von
null auf hundert siebter juli 85
boris becker jungs der wimbledonsieger
bis heute er wird zu einer der ikonen
des deutschen sports bis ins gefängnis
wegen insolvenzverschleppung ein weiter
weg millionen mit tennis als werbefigur
geld kommt rein und geht noch schneller
ein luxuriöser lebensstil teure
scheidungen allein seine erste ehefrau
barbara bekommt 15 millionen euro 6
millionen plus unterhalt für anna
tochter aus der besenkammer-affäre kein
glück als unternehmer
2017 zahltag becker wohnsitz london wird
für bankrott erklärt geschätzte schulden
60 millionen euro im anschließenden
insolvenzverfahren unterschlägt er
vermögenswerte in millionenhöhe er hätte
auf milde hoffen können doch da stand
sich becker die häufig selbst im weg
die richterin hat erklärt dass becker
keine reue oder demut gezeigt habe nicht
einmal ein anflug von entschuldigung das
hätte die schwere seiner tat
relativieren können weniger hochmut und
becker hätte weniger zeit hinter gittern
absitzen müssen
vielleicht sogar auf bewährung beckers
verteidigungsstrategie die berater seien
schuld gewesen er zu jung zu berühmt
geworden falsche freunde schon immer
hoffnungslos mit geld die richterin
machte damit klar unwissenheit und
unfähigkeit schützend vor strafe nicht
und keinesfalls prominenz
momentan wird in großbritannien viel
darüber nachgedacht wie reiche berühmte
menschen für ihre taten belangen können
insolvenzverwalter und gerichtsbarkeit
sind sehr bemüht zu demonstrieren dass
man mit so etwas nicht mehr einfach
davon kommt zurück bleiben eine
geschockte lebensgefährtin
der älteste sohn noah die ihn heute
begleitet hatten sprachlos er habe
großes einmaliges für das deutsche
tennis geleistet erklärt etwa der
präsident des deutschen tennis bundes
seine knochen hingehalten sein körper
gefunden doch becker hat sich danach
ebenfalls viel geleistet zu viel in
frühestens 15 monaten kann er aus dem
gefängnis und wieder zeigen was ihnen
auf dem platz ausgezeichnet hat sich aus
schwierigsten situationen zurückkämpfen
tja wir werden das verfolgen und noch
immer nachrichten aus der wirtschaft
handwerk die deutsche wirtschaft hat
trotz der schwierigen gesamtlage zu
jahresbeginn ein leichtes plus verbucht
von 0,2 gegenüber dem vorquartal hat
eine erste schätzung des statistischen
bundesamtes ergeben weil die halle was
lässt sich daraus über die lage der
deutschen wirtschaft ablesen daraus
liest sich ab dass die deutsche
wirtschaft gerade noch so an einer
rezession vorbei geschrammt ist die
vorzeichen aber die sind nicht besonders
gut vor allem weil die vollen
auswirkungen des krieges in den
aktuellen zahlen ja noch gar nicht
enthalten sind die zeigen sich erst mit
voller wucht ab dem zweiten quartal
größtes problem für die deutsche
wirtschaft schon jetzt ist die teure
energie denn sie bedeutet hohe kosten
für unternehmen und heizt die inflation
insgesamt an höhere preise wiederum
dämpfen den konsum außerdem verschärft
der krieg die lieferengpässe die sich
durch chinas 0-coup politik noch
drastisch verschärfen könnten manche
meinen sogar chinas selbstisolation sei
die aktuell größte gefahr für die
weltwirtschaft der materialmangel und
die hohen preise machen auch den bau zu
schaffen schon lange nicht mehr waren
die geschäftserwartungen in der branche
so pessimistisch der bausektor war eine
wichtige konjunkturstütze in der korona
pandemie doch ausgerechnet die droht
jetzt wegzubrechen noch rechnen ökonomen
mit einem wachstum dieses jahr das aber
wir wären nicht zu halten wenn es zu
einem abrupten gasstopp aus russland
kämen denn das würde voll auf die
industrie durch schlagen die auf
russisches gas angewiesen ist basf warnt
seit wochen vor einem embargo auch heute
wieder auf der hauptversammlung im
extremfall so basf-chef brudermüller
müsste die produktion in ludwigshafen
eingestellt werden ballaballa vielen
dank
nach zwei jahren pause wegen corona soll
das oktoberfest in münchen in diesem
jahr wieder stattfinden das gab
oberbürgermeister reiter bekannt corona
beschränkungen wird es demnach nicht
geben
die aktuelle hitzewelle in nordindien
und pakistan droht sich laut der
weltwetterorganisation zu verschlimmern
war als heute betrogen die temperaturen
vielerorts mehr als 45 grad und erst
kommende woche sei ein abflachen der
temperaturen in sicht die für diese
jahreszeit ungewöhnlich hohen
temperaturen bedrohen vor allem die
stromversorgung in beiden ländern so
warnten die behörden in neu delhi das
viele kraftwerke nur noch weniger als
einen tag laufen könnten verbunden etwa
mit der starke luftverschmutzung bringe
die hitzewelle menschen an ihre
anpassungs grenzen so experten
der mais steht vor der tür und damit
auch zwei wichtigen landtagswahlen in
nordrhein westfalen mitte des monats und
am sonntag in einer woche in schleswig
holstein dort sieht es nach einem
aktuellen politbarometer derzeit nach
einem wahlsieg von cdu ministerpräsident
daniel günther aus der mit grünen und
fdp in kiel regiert die projektion sieht
die cdu neun tage vor der wahl
jedenfalls klar in führung die stimmung
in ganz deutschland misst das
bundesweite politbarometer und die
ergebnisse zeigt uns jetzt matthias
fornoff
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
es war eine schwierige entscheidung in
berlin schwere waffen wie etwa panzer
für die ukraine ja oder nein einfach an
die cdu forderte das vehement aber auch
die regierungsparteien grüne und fdp die
spd war lange uneins am ende stand ein
gemeinsamer antrag von union und
ampelkoalition der mit großer mehrheit
im bundestag angenommen wurde
56 prozent der befragten finden es
richtig dass deutschland diesen schritt
geht und der ukraine schwere waffen zur
verfügung stellt 39 prozent finden das
falsch das ist ein meinungsumschwung
dennoch im märz haben nur 31 prozent die
lieferung von schwerem gerät befürwortet
63 prozent lehnten das ab
den deutschen ist klar russland schaute
sehr genau auf die waffenlieferungen des
westens an die ukraine dass dadurch die
gefahr eines russischen angriffs auf
westliche staaten wächst nimmt eine
mehrheit an
generell glauben nur 38 prozent dass der
krieg auf die ukraine beschränkt bleibt
eine mehrheit von 54 prozent befürchtet
dass russland noch weitere länder
angreifen wird
die solidarität mit der ukraine ist groß
gut 60 prozent sind dafür das land in
den nächsten jahren in die eu
aufzunehmen und mehr als 80 prozent sind
sich sicher die vielen ukrainischen
flüchtlinge kann deutschland verkraften
die unterstützung die die ukraine
insgesamt durch die bundesregierung
erhält findet die hälfte gerade richtig
32 prozent meinen dass es noch zu wenig
und 13 prozent sagen die regierung macht
zu viel diese gruppe wächst um sechs
prozentpunkte im vergleich zur letzten
umfrage
kanzler vizekanzler
wirtschaftsminister und außenministerin
sind in diesen zeiten besonders gefragt
bei der bewertung ihres handelns zeigt
sich ein klares bild und ein klarer
trend die zustimmung zu kanzler stolz
nimmt ab noch im märz meinten fast drei
viertel der befragten er mache seine
sache in der ukraine krise eher gut
inzwischen sagt dass nur noch knapp die
hälfte vom gegenteil sind 43 prozent
überzeugt mit vizekanzler und
wirtschaftsminister habeck sind in der
krise 66 prozent der deutschen zufrieden
19 prozent nicht
außenministerin berbalk bekommt mit 70
prozent zustimmung an noch etwas
besseres zeugnis allerdings bewerten
auch 24 prozent ihr handeln kritisch
doppel grün also vor rot das trifft auch
auf unsere top ten zu hier die liste der
wichtigsten politikerinnen und politiker
sortiert nach sympathie und leistung auf
der skala von +5 bis -5
schlusslicht sahra wagenknecht minus 0,9
neu dabei auf platz neun christine
lambrecht minus 0,4 dann friedrich merz
minus 0,1 markus söder minus 0,1 karl
lauterbach 0,6 alle drei etwas
schlechter davor christian lindner 0,7
verbessert cem özdemir 1,0 und auf platz
3 olaf scholz 1,1 deutlich
verschlechtert davor annalena baerbock
1,4 leichte verluste und ganz vorn
robert habeck 1,9 unverändert von den
köpfen zu den parteien auch hier läuft
es gut für die grünen wenn am nächsten
sonntag wirklich bundestagswahl wäre
dann käme die spd auf 25 prozent minus 2
cdu/csu bei 23 prozent minus 1 die
grünen 21 prozent +2 fdp 9 prozent plus
1 die fdp 11 linke bei vier prozent
beide unverändert
alle anderen parteien zusammen kämen auf
7 prozent
kommen wir noch zum thema corona da hat
sich eine gewisse gelassenheit
eingestellt eine mehrheit der deutschen
hält die eigene gesundheit nicht für
gefährdet das ist schon seit ende januar
so was aber den wegfall der allermeisten
corona schutzmaßnahmen betrifft sind die
befragten gespalten
48 prozent begrüßen dass 51 prozent
nicht vor allem die anhänger von afg und
fdp finden den wegfall der maßnahmen
mehrheitlich richtig im gegensatz dazu
sind vor allem die anhänger von union
und grünen skeptisch
im herbst erwarten 86 prozent der
deutschen dann doch wieder eine neue
corona welle es mischt sich also die
hoffnung auf wieder gewonnene freiheiten
mit der sorge vor erneut steigenden
falls sein
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und oft zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer punkt
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer für den bund gibt
es dann am 20 und vorher bereits
politbarometer extra ausgaben zu den
landtagswahlen in schleswig-holstein und
nordrhein-westfalen
nach dem wetter geht es hier weiter mit
der heute show danke für ihr interesse
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend morgen geht der april zu
ende und die temperaturen lagen im april
in deutschland bei 7,8 grad im schnitt
fielen 55 liter regen pro quadratmeter
und es gab
195 sonnenstunden wenn dir das
vergleichen mit dem vieljährigen
klimatologischen mittelwert der jahre
1961 bis 1990 war es 0,4 grad wärmer es
gab fünf prozent weniger regen und 20
prozent mehr sonne wenn wir uns
vergleichen mit dem vieljährigen
klimatologischen mittel der jahre 1991
bis 2020 hingegen war diese april 1,2
grad kälter es gab 25 prozent mehr regen
und 5 prozent mehr sonne jetzt schauen
wir in die nahe zukunft in der nacht
gibt es schauer und gewitter im westen
und den südwesten deutschlands im
nordosten ist es dagegen klar die
temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 2 grad
und steigen morgen rund um berlin oder
dresden auf 18 bis 20 grad meist werden
13 bis 17 grad erreicht an der
nordseeküste und am alpenrand bleibt es
bei elf grad kühler besonders in
süddeutschland gibt es morgen kräftige
schauer und gewitter da sehen sie kaum
mal die sonne im norden ist es deutlich
freundlicher sehr freundliches wetter da
wechseln sonne und wolken miteinander ab
am sonntag ziehen schauer und gewitter
dann weiter richtung südosten bei
temperaturen von 12 bis 17 grad werden
sie dann auch am oberrhein und an der
mosel mal wieder die sonne sehen können
und die neue woche startet ganz ähnlich
meist mit freundlichem wetter genannt